you're looking into some of California's
options does the state have any options
besides these mandatory water cuts the
governor has imposed right the state
does have options but they're either for
the midterm or the longer-term future
you know we're talking about these 25%
water cuts right now from this past week
but that's not going to be enough some
other technologies as you talked about
are things like drought resistant crops
but that of course is going to take
years to develop
another possibility is desalination
plants now one is coming up over the
next few years it was actually
mothballed in the 1990s and another one
is coming up I believe in Carlsberg
California Carlsbad California for the
to the tune about 1 billion dollars but
again this is gonna take a long time
coming and we just don't and still time
we doing a fraction of the exactly
cities watering that Carlsbad it's only
about 7% of San Diego's water supply so
that's we're gonna need about what 12
more desalination plans to reach that
city's water supply okay they can't just
truck water in it's very expensive to do
that just like it's expensive to do salt
sea water so that's as far as you're
concerned that's an enviable option you
can truck water in four small
communities where you're not trusting
you for very far but otherwise it's a
lot cheaper to do additional one sort of
conservation for big metropolitan areas
or or to do wastewater reuse and
treatment Jay I think it helps if you
know we sort of present the California
problem in stark terms and one way to
look at it is to evaluate California's
agriculture industry or certain crops
against the value of other industries
and cities that rely on a lot of water I
tried to do why I did some a little bit
of research this morning and came up
with a couple of figures that I want to
throw at you and see what you think the
almond crop among the most water
intensive in the state is valued at
about five billion dollars annually
Hollywood entertainment is valued at
about 50 billion dollars annually if you
suck Los Angeles dry clearly that's not
good for Hollywood should be framing
things in these terms well I think you
have to be a little more careful in the
sense that about half of all the urban
water uses in California which is
two or three times the average for the
rest of United States is for keeping our
lawns green because we have a very dry
summer in our climate here in California
so there's a lot of room for urban water
conservation before you start to bite
into the major industries hey it's
raining here sorry yeah I just want to
ask you a question about the crops that
are being used over in California a lot
of these are very thirsty crops
including as a Eric you talked about
almonds it actually takes one gallon of
water to make one single almond and they
actually produce rice in California and
they're sending that to Asia so why are
these even allowed to be grown in the
state well because they make more money
per drop it's really relevant is not the
tons per per per gallon
but the but the money per gallon that
these farms are all businesses and so
they do a lot better if you allow them
to grow the most profitable crops Jay
why aren't Californians more at war with
each other over this issue the folks in
San Francisco and Santa Cruz and even
Sacramento for that matter used vastly
less water than their peers and cities
like San Diego or worst of all in a
place like Palm Springs well I think the
price does need to be said about right
and that would provide the right
incentives for people to use less water
or use water more appropriately so in
other words if you priced water the way
we price gasoline let's say it would
create the kinds of incentives to drive
more appropriate behavior regarding the
use of water that's correct and
particularly in the agricultural sector
we're looking at trying to improve water
markets so that water can move from
lower value crops to higher value crops
are your typical Californians respecting
these restrictions abiding by them well
I think they will we're still at the end
of our rainy season today in fact today
we have a little bit of a rain storm
here outside of Sacramento so I think
we'll see as it gets warmer and the
water utilities start enforcing things
and coming up with their pricing
structures for the for the drought that
we'll we'll see unbalanced that the
governor's orders will be complied with
and agriculture will continue to see the
very large sorta jiz they've seen for
several years now
you know J in my research I was finding
vets Americans use some of the most
water per capita in the world one figure
that I came from the CIA world factbook
was a 1500 cubic meters of water a per
person per year but relative to people
say in Europe in the United Kingdom and
in Germany that's up only about 200 or
400 cubic meters of water per year so
what's the what's the difference what
are we doing wrong or what can we do
even better over here in the u.s. well
some of it is just different kinds of
accounting of water use for urban water
use we in California tend to use a lot
relative to other parts of the world and
other parts of the United States because
we have a very dry summer and we like to
have East Coast landscapes on the west
coast where we have a dry summer so that
requires a lot of watering if if you're
in the middle of a drought we can pretty
easily cut back urban water use quite a
bit by restricting lawn watering without
really much harm to the core of the
economy however if you go to rural areas
and you have mandatory cutbacks on some
of the rural areas when they don't need
to anyway then you can be imposing a lot
of economic hardship without much
purpose